you just don't know and i'm 48 this
happened when he was 47. he's way
healthier than i
am it can happen to anybody you know and
you're right you we can't
always live our life in a place of this
could happen at any point
but i do think if we can for example if
we knew that this was happening
it even in that time when that was going
on it changes how you interact with
people
and so i think if we could just honor
the preciousness of life
then i think it would change how we
interact with people it would
certain things that i would you know
slip out about
i'm i probably wouldn't if i knew that
this moment was going to be my last
moment or this moment was going to be in
your last moment or next week was going
to be your last moment
so i think if we can move forward in our
life in that under that umbrella
and i think our through that lens anyway
would really help the way that we
interact with people because a lot of
times it's like you know what it's not
that serious
like this this thing right here that
this little thing that's happening it's
not that serious i can
i can let that slide you know what i i
would rather tell you that i love you
before i leave
instead of saying you it comes back
to kindness right
it's so easy to just be kind and be
aware of that and it's okay for me to
still be upset about something it's like
i don't need to take it
there all the time i can just you know
one of my favorite words is grace it's
like you know i can just let a little
bit of grace
flow from outside of me and hopefully
some will come back my way too in the
midst of
if i just you know in the midst of
things because i have learned
i lost my best friend when i was 15
years old so now i have learned that
when when even a person that you can't
stand
a person you really know that you really
can't stand even when they
go away you know you realize that a lot
of those things weren't as serious not
saying
i'm not saying all of them were some of
them are major but there's a lot of
things
like you know what that wasn't really
that serious i didn't need to
hold on to that so like weighed that
like a banner
everywhere i went i could have just said
like you know i could have let that
let that go by the wayside so yeah
that's uh
that's one thing that i mean thankfully
tim has persevered through but even in
that moment it kind of just reminded me
of how
how fragile life is so let's try our
best to enjoy it
it's just truly a truly appreciating
what you have
informs every and every element of your
behavior and that's another thing that
we've been conditioned
by in this industry is like it's never
enough right it's like it doesn't matter
how good we have it or what's in front
of us our eyes are always
okay but what's the next thing what's
the next what can i turn this into right
what can i
how can i take this and leverage it and
turn it into that and
so i think a lot of times we forget how
fleeting it all is
and how important it is to just
stop and
and enjoy and savor and appreciate the
moments that we have
in this business especially because so
many other people don't get them
and that that informs how you act that
informs how you treat people
and i think other people i don't think
people are
automatically resentful of someone just
because they're successful
i think if people see a successful
person appreciating that success
and using it to help others they can be
thrilled for that
i think i think resentment is born from
watching
people become successful you know
and then it trickles down so
appreciation i think it is another
another word that i
along with grace